all right that time of year has come the
beginning of another year first of all
happy new year hope you had a fun one
and hope 2022 is off to a great start
for you this is that time of the year
the beginning of a new year which means
i give you my top 10 anticipated movies
of said year you're being 2022 that time
of year i lay the groundwork for you to
know my taste in movies at the beginning
of the year so you don't feel blindsided
when i do my top 10 favorites of the
year at the end of the year look i've
never hidden my taste in movies in the
course of the past 12 years if you don't
know me by now that's on you but this
list is in a general order it's mostly
in the order of release there's some
that got shuffled around doesn't matter
not going to do the countdown 10 9876
thing but i start out with the first
movie i'm looking forward to which is
scream
just called scream it's scream five
feels a little weird putting this movie
on my list because it comes out what
next week but it's a new scream movie
and if scream four had sucked i wouldn't
be looking forward to this but it didn't
suck it was a great return to form after
scream three which was disappointing
it's one of those fingers cross kind of
moments there are a lot of leaps of
faith on this list this is just one of
them i'm like i hope it's good don't
make dewey the bad guy that's all i ask
don't do that next up is the batman
looking forward to battenson showing
what he's got because quite frankly the
trailers have been nothing but great the
tone is like this realistic take on
batman but still feels comic book this
one of the the complaints the gripes i
hear about the christopher nolan batman
trilogy is people are like it doesn't
feel like comic book batman it feels
like batman in the real world which is
what nolan was going for but this feels
like dark gritty down to earth realistic
batman
in the sense that it still does feel
like comic book batman at least from the
trailers it looks like a cool best of
both world scenarios that got going on
looking forward to this one next up
sonic 2 in which they're using that
lock-on technology and using knuckles in
sonic 2 idris elba's knuckles is kind of
amazing casting but more than that the
first sonic the hedgehog movie was one
of the surprises of the year for me glad
they didn't go with that monstrosity of
creature design for sonic they initially
had it's like they're like oh fans are
pissed but we're gonna do this
unexpected twist for a studio
we're gonna listen to them they came out
with a movie that i thought was
remarkably fun and jim carrey was
amazing in it they give me more of that
fun i'm in this next one it's mostly
morbid curiosity probably but also
the premise is so genius and the trailer
was so good the unbearable weight of
massive talent it's got to be good right
i don't want to jinx it but i'm just
saying nicholas cage playing nicholas
cage in a very nicholas cage self-aware
movie i love nick cage because the
dude's a good actor he's a great actor
but he's still able to lean into this
very self-aware nic cage meme culture
and he was like yeah all right memes
about me we'll make a movie about that
more or less you know i just love seeing
an actor have fun with the perception of
them on the internet the premise is so
genius that if it sucks this is a movie
on here i might cry if that movie sucks
i might be like oh well you know
can't win them all next up doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness you
know for the longest time i thought it
was doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness but it's actually in
the
whatever this wouldn't have actually
been on the list i'm like oh yeah doctor
strange multiverse i get is probably
cool but i saw the trailer at the end of
spider-man no way home and the trailer
looked really good it's like a movie
that's the continuation of what if which
i thought what if was just this weird
one-off like okay it's a thing that
happened and even if it canonically it's
like oh yeah it happened because
multiverse and all the stuff we're doing
i didn't expect a movie to tie into it
to the degree that the trailer looks
like it's tying into it that trailer
moved it up the list it's amazing what a
trailer can do and actually you know i
like me some action movies you know i
like solid action movies you know i love
me some keanu in some solid action
movies john wick 4 or john wick chapter
4. they're called chapters sorry
so john wick chapter four was delayed to
2023 which i just found out about all
right i'll find another movie and plug
it in here and make it an even ten or
i'll leave it at nine i don't know while
i'm figuring that out i'm still in an
action movie headspace so going straight
to mission impossible seven probably has
a another name to it it's not just
mission impossible seven is it angel
half ghost protocol fallout whatever
it's gonna be called looking forward to
the new mission impossible generally
speaking tom cruise is on cruise control
in his action movies the dude's still
got it i hope i have that much vigor i
hope i'm not spry when i'm 60 sorry 59
mean no disrespect point is the mission
impossible movies are reliably
entertaining movies and they'll probably
be on my anticipated list any given year
they're coming out and one would think
i'm all spider-man out by now but
apparently i'm not because spider-man
across the spider-verse
part one is on this list into the
spider-verse is an undeniably great time
the spider-verse has now it's it's
live-action it's animated it's
everywhere the movies look cool they got
great soundtracks all of that spider-man
flavor that you love this is the thing
the caveat of these into the
spider-verse movies is just the frame
rate that's what bothers me about them i
don't know if it's the former
projectionist in me or the editor in me
there's something about when it cuts to
16 frames a second it just bothers me
other than that into the spiderverse was
a great movie looking forward to across
the spider-verse again part one these
next two movies i'm pretty sure coming
out in 2022 i mean they're slated to
come out in 2022 we'll see but avatar
too anyone looking forward to avatar too
am i the only one all right cool i mean
the movie's been delayed for about a
decade i can't help but look forward to
it like a decade of pushbacks in the
world of james cameron just means a
decade of advancement technologically
speaking i can't help but look forward
to that and i know avatar gets a lot of
crappers like this dances with wolves
and that's pretty much that's the stance
of the wolf but i still get a kick out
of avatar for nothing else
technologically speaking it it did tell
hollywood like we're here now we're here
we can't go there anymore we have we're
here wedda did a great job with this
movie as much as avatar felt like a
movie that was written in the 80s or 90s
it's because it was just didn't have the
technology to be made yet but now that's
not the case avatar two is like okay now
it's written recently so we know the
cliches we know the tropes let's steer
away from them that steer clear of those
and we'll make a movie that feels newer
in terms of the story hopeful optimist
on this side of the camera we'll see how
it goes and also this last one the
internet word is that this is coming out
this year uh the whale darren
aronofsky's new film starring brendan
fraser
can't help but look forward to that
every time i do these lists there are
two names that i google they're like
okay let's make sure that let's see if
they're doing a movie this year because
if they are
they have their spot reserved on my list
tarantino is not doing a movie this year
but he's one of those directors and
darren aronofsky darren aronofsky films
are emotional soul-driven odysseys of
the human condition done in a movie with
interesting characters that are
soul-wrenching and sometimes
soul-changing events and just the fusion
of brendan fraser and darren aronofsky
it's i wouldn't have called it but i'm
glad i don't make those decisions i'm
glad he does because that's pretty
awesome looking forward to what
aronofsky gives us and looking forward
to how brandon frazier delivers it and i
really hope the movie does come out in
like google says it will but yeah that's
the list in a world of cinematic
surprises that happen every year they're
going to be a number of movies that i
don't know about i don't know about now
i can't put them on the list but then
they'll come out and i'll be like wow
wish i knew about that back in january
fingers crossed i don't have to talk
about any of these movies with glass of
scotch in hand
talking about the worst movies of the
year
here's hoping but as always it doesn't
matter you all keep this channel afloat
so i ask you and yes i do read comments
my gosh who do you think i am but your
10 anticipated movies of 2022 or 5 or 3
or whatever number whatever they are
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]
you